este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
link das link es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que te permite
generar contraseñas seguras almacenar
las guardar tu información personal y de
pago guardar notas de forma segura
en definitiva proteger tu privacidad
todo de forma rápida y sencilla beatas
link.com barra visual polític s y
descárgate lo de forma totalmente
gratuita además usando el código visual
polític s podrás probar la versión
premium totalmente gratis durante 30
días y luego si decides continuar con
ella tendrás un 10% de descuento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos en 1971 el premio nobel
de economía
simon kuznets afirmó que había cuatro
tipos de países de acuerdo a su
desempeño económico los países
desarrollados los países
subdesarrollados la argentina y japón
[Música]
i
amigos de argentina y japón son dos
países que se enfrentan hoy a muchos
problemas económicos pero cuya evolución
en el tiempo no podría haber sido más
diferente ha sido una trayectoria tan
distinta que nos surgen algunas
preguntas que diferentes caminos han
seguido la argentina y japón- en que se
han aparecido en que han sido diferentes
[Música]
porque el país nipón una isla rocosa y
sin recursos naturales pudo progresar y
porque la argentina con un enorme
territorio y una enorme abundancia de
recursos no puede escapar de su estado
de crisis crónica en este vídeo te lo
contamos una persona por otra parte
adaptado a los aires
para plasmar más caminos opuestos
[Música]
hay acaso países condenados al éxito y
otros al fracaso son los recursos
naturales una bendición o un castigo
como era la economía de argentina
comparada con la de japón en la primera
mitad del siglo 20
amigos a comienzos del siglo 20 las
diferencias entre la argentina y japón
eran abismales claro que en sentido
inverso a lo que ocurre hoy
[Música]
argentina era un país mucho más
desarrollado tenía recursos naturales
una población bien formada y un comercio
abierto al mundo era toda una potencia
[Música]
mientras tanto japón era un país mucho
menos desarrollado y con instituciones
muy tradicionales
[Música]
si nos hubieran pedido un pronóstico en
aquel momento probablemente todos
hubiéramos aventurado que la argentina
continuaría compitiendo por ser el país
más rico del planeta mientras que en el
caso de japón la lucha sería por poco
más que la subsistencia
[Música]
tal vez lo que más diferenciaba a estos
dos países eran los recursos naturales
fijaos mientras que el territorio
argentino es fértil y está lleno de
recursos la madre naturaleza nunca fue
generosa con los japoneses japonés una
pequeña cadena de islas rocosas con muy
poco territorio habitable expuesto a
todo tipo de catástrofes naturales y sin
prácticamente ningún tipo de recurso
destacable
[Música]
por si todo esto fuera poco en 1945 la
segunda guerra mundial terminó con el
lanzamiento sobre japón de las dos
únicas bombas nucleares que se han
utilizado en una guerra en ese momento
de este país estaba arrasado las
ciudades las infraestructuras y la
industria habían sido en gran medida
destruidas más de tres millones de
japoneses especialmente jóvenes habían
perdido su vida y los más de diez
millones de soldados que retornaban del
frente no tenían trabajo
[Música]
en 1945 nadie hubiera apostado por el
futuro de japón
insisto lo que si hubiéramos hecho
prácticamente todos hubiera sido sin
duda apostar por el futuro de argentina
amigos a principios del siglo 20 este
país era algo así como el faro de
latinoamérica su economía estaba entre
las diez mayores del planeta tenía los
niveles de desarrollo social más altos
su red ferroviaria no paraba de crecer
el sistema educativo estaba muy
desarrollado y el país tenía una gran
participación en el mercado mundial de
capitales
como ejemplo podemos recordar que en
aquellos años argentina era uno de los
principales receptores de inversión
directa europea uno de los mayores
exportadores de bienes primarios del
mundo y el segundo destino para los
inmigrantes del viejo continente sí por
aquella época alemanes italianos y
españoles emigraban en masa la argentina
vamos que era un país que miraba de tú a
tú a los mismísimos eeuu
esto es lo que explica como en aquellos
años la ciudad de buenos aires no tenía
nada que envidiar ni a londres ni a
nueva york- ni a ninguna otra ciudad del
mundo y encima durante la segunda guerra
mundial ni siquiera participó en el
conflicto de verdad no me digáis que no
hubierais apostado por la argentina yo
hasta el último centavo sin embargo he
esperado un momento porque las cosas
pronto empezaron a cambiar echad un
vistazo a este gráfico
[Música]
a comienzos del siglo 20 el producto
interior bruto per cápita de argentina
era el triple que el de japón la brecha
se mantuvo hasta el final de la segunda
guerra mundial sin embargo a partir de
la década de los 50 ya se empieza a
observar un cambio significativo de
repente japón empezó a recortar la
diferencia a toda velocidad de tal forma
que a finales de los años 60 el país del
sol naciente ya había superado a la
argentina desde entonces la distancia no
ha hecho más que crecer
[Música]
así que la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es qué diantres ocurrió para que esto
ocurrirá que hizo japón que no hizo la
argentina atentos
japon versus argentina
el territorio de argentina es 77 veces
más grande que el de japón mientras que
la población argentina es apenas un
tercio de la población nipona
[Música]
pero ojo como ya os hemos dicho la
densidad no es la única diferencia
además el territorio argentino frente a
lo que ocurre con el japonés es muy
fértil y cuenta con un montón de
recursos naturales de todo tipo petróleo
gas natural oro plata cobre carbón
hierro litio literalmente la argentina
tiene de todo
[Música]
la argentina es el sexto país con mayor
cantidad de recursos mineros en el mundo
[Música]
claro que contar con las condiciones
naturales no implica que producir sea
algo sencillo durante el siglo 19
argentina los inversores argentinos
invirtieron muchísimo dinero en máquinas
e infraestructuras para que el país se
convirtiera en uno de los mayores
productores de alimentos del mundo a
principios del siglo 20
en aquel momento el sistema político y
las instituciones argentinas como el
derecho de propiedad o la libertad de
comercio animaban a los inversores a
invertir su dinero en la argentina por
su parte durante la segunda mitad del
siglo 19 japón realizó cambios en esa
misma dirección os lo hemos contado ya
aquí en visual político en un vídeo que
os dejo en la descripción fue lo que se
conoció como la restauración meiji sin
embargo como los cambios fueron más
lentos y las condiciones de origen más
difíciles el resultado a principios del
siglo 20 era el que ya hemos visto y
luego vino la segunda guerra mundial
[Música]
fijaos al terminar este conflicto
mientras que japón era un país arruinado
o quebrado y estaba destruido la
argentina- que lo había pasado mal
durante la crisis del 29 era un país
próspero incluso era todo un acreedor
internacional de países como inglaterra
así que con una posición financiera
sólida muchos recursos naturales una
población bien formada sin la amenaza de
ninguna guerra o conflicto una clase
media en expansión y una enorme demanda
mundial de alimentos las perspectivas
para el país del tango no podían ser
mejores
pero amigos vayamos a la cuestión
principal donde comenzaron argentina y
japón a transitar por caminos tan
diferentes
[Música]
pues veréis tras la segunda guerra
mundial de una forma y otra japón fue
poco a poco asimilando y copiando muchos
de los elementos que habían hecho ricos
a los eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en esto tuvo precisamente mucho que ver
la ocupación estadounidense al mando del
general douglas macarthur líder del
comando supremo de las fuerzas aliadas
estas fuerzas de ocupación tenían como
objetivo desmilitarizar y democratizar
la sociedad japonesa para conseguirlo se
reescribe la constitución y se copiaron
muchas de las instituciones de los eeuu
como por ejemplo la limitación del poder
el tamaño del gobierno la protección de
la propiedad privada o la libertad de
empresa y comercio es decir japón se
abrió al mundo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mientras tanto amigos en la argentina ha
pasado todo lo contrario en febrero de
1946 asumió la presidencia del país juan
domingo perón
la turba con él llegó el auténtico
cambio de modelo para la argentina
de pronto el estado empezó a incrementar
su tamaño y su influencia en la economía
y en la sociedad argentina fijaos se
nacionalizaron un montón de empresas
especialmente las dedicadas al
transporte la energía y las
comunicaciones se puso a la banca bajo
el control del gobierno y se aprobaron
un montón de restricciones al comercio
exterior además de un montón de
regulaciones de todo tipo
[Música]
en la práctica amigos juan domingo perón
transformó a la argentina en una especie
de ejército a las órdenes de un caudillo
su presidente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para poder llevar a cabo sus planes la
constitución liberal de 1853 fue
cambiada por otra de corte peronista en
1949 durante los 10 años que duró su
gobierno las distorsiones creadas por el
estado sobre la actividad económica
fueron tan grandes que los argentinos
llegaron a tener que comer pan negro y
reaccionar su consumo de carne
[Música]
y no precisamente por ninguna moda
vegana ni nada por el estilo sino por
escasez los productores argentinos
preferían dejar de producir antes que
cumplir con los controles de precios o
tipos de cambio que estableció el
gobierno
[Música]
y ojo porque la salida del poder de
perón no supuso ningún cambio relevante
si se reintrodujeron algunas libertades
económicas y se suprimieron algunos
controles pero el peso el tamaño y la
intromisión del estado en la actividad
económica no retrocedieron el gasto
público los altos impuestos y la
inflación habían llegado a argentina
para quedarse
[Música]
amigos el giro de timón de la argentina
dado por perón se convirtió en algo
definitivo y a ello hay que sumarle la
inestabilidad política causada por los
golpes militares un desastre que ha
provocado que en argentina las crisis se
sucedan una y otra vez cada cinco o diez
años
[Música]
el resultado como todos sabéis es que
hoy la argentina ya no es uno de los
diez países más ricos del mundo ni
tampoco uno de los 25 ni siquiera uno de
los 50 según los datos de la fm y en
paridad de poder adquisitivo esto es
teniendo en cuenta la diferencia de
precios argentina ocupa el puesto 62 de
los países con mayor pib per cápita es
decir está al mismo nivel que países
como irán belorrusia o gabón
[Música]
y tras la última crisis es de esperar
que caiga aún más hoy un 32 por ciento
de los argentinos 1 de cada 3 viven en
la pobreza argentina es uno de los pocos
países del mundo donde la pobreza crece
en lugar de disminuir
en fin amigos así es cómo evolucionaron
japón y argentinas en visual político
que hemos visto con detalle en varios
vídeos como argentina y japón se
convirtieron en lo que son hoy pero
ahora la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es podemos extraer algunas claves de la
comparación de estos dos países pues
creo que sí fijaos
[Música]
las claves vamos a ver de la comparación
entre argentina y japón podemos extraer
tres claves tres ideas principales que
creo debemos tener siempre muy pero que
muy en cuenta la primera dejémoslo claro
de una vez es que un país no es rico o
pobre por los recursos naturales o el
tamaño que tenga de nada sirve tener
ingentes recursos si no se explotan
adecuadamente en cambio un país como es
el caso de japón puede ser muy rico sin
tener recursos naturales o mucho
territorio
lo que importa amigos lo que realmente
importa para generar riqueza es el nivel
de capital de inversión y de trabajo que
hay en un país la innovación y la
productividad son muchísimo pero que
muchísimo más importantes que cualquier
recurso natural la segunda idea es que
el hecho de que un país alcance un alto
nivel de desarrollo y prosperidad no
significa en absoluto que el mismo país
se vaya a sostener en el tiempo de forma
indefinida la riqueza no existe per se
hay que crearla permanentemente y
adaptarse a los cambios que se producen
en el mundo de lo contrario te puede
pasar como a la argentina que ha pasado
de ser el país más rico de la tierra a
estar en el puesto 62 y desde luego eso
es malo para todos especialmente para la
población más desfavorecida castigar a
la economía productiva es siempre
siempre una pésima idea
[Música]
la tercera idea es que la riqueza no se
logra haciendo que los gobiernos gasten
y gasten y gasten a lo loco el gasto
público sólo se puede financiar mediante
tres métodos más impuestos más deuda
pública o dándole a la máquina de
imprimir billetes es decir causando
inflación los tres son métodos que no
provocan más que crisis y pobreza hay
que ser muy exigentes con dónde va a
parar el gasto público si queremos que
nuestros países sean prósperos y si no
os lo creéis echado un vistazo a
venezuela además de otro ala argentina
el fin amigos
esta es la comparación de cómo han
evolucionado la argentina y japón y qué
podemos aprender de ellos y tú nos ves
desde argentina o desde japón pues sabes
que no importa desde donde nos veas
porque tu privacidad no entiende de
fronteras y la mejor herramienta para
protegerla tiene un nombre das line
con daschle y mantendrá su identidad
online segura does lente protegerá de
todo tipo de amenazas contra tu
identidad
hay muchos hackers allí fuera y la mejor
manera de esquivar los es utilizando
dash le das link es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que incluye un vpn
para todos tus dispositivos de tal forma
que puedas usar redes públicas de manera
segura y anónima también hace una cosa
llamada monitoreo de la tar web y esto
que es pues consiste en escanear la web
en busca de datos personales filtrados o
robados alertando te al instante en caso
de que tus datos personales se
encuentren donde no deben estar de tal
forma que puedas tomar medidas
rápidamente y por supuesto das lane te
ayudará a generar contraseñas seguras y
cada vez que una web te pida
introducirlas te ayudará a rellenar los
campos requeridos de forma rápida y
sencilla es súper cómodo como os decía
antes das link es totalmente gratuito
pero hay algunas opciones premium
en caso de que quieras disponer de más
servicios bien pues si entra sendas line
puntocom
visual polític s usando el código visual
polític s tendrás una prueba de estas
opciones premium totalmente gratis
durante 30 días y si decides después
continuar con ellas obtendrás un 10% de
descuento a la hora de contratar les no
lo dudes entra en el link que te hemos
dejado en la descripción y descarga te
estás link de forma gratuita
no te olvides tampoco de suscribirte a
visual político si aún no lo has hecho y
si ya has visto todos nuestros vídeos
anímate con nuestro canal en inglés y
aprovecha para repasar un poco la lengua
de shakespeare y como siempre un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]